You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost! Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water.
你说这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那几步路。我们省了多少钱？够了。足够让我们迷路了！或者你可以预订希尔顿酒店的住宿。欢迎来到你的海滨客房。距离水边仅几步之遥。
The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay. Some kids are the life of every party and the lead in every school play, while others are quiet in class and keep to a small circle of friends.
希尔顿促销活动现已开启。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿应用程序上预订，最高可享 8 折优惠，获得你期待的住宿体验。当你想要的是节省开支，而不是意外惊喜时。住哪里很重要。希尔顿，为你提供理想住宿。有些孩子是每个派对的焦点，也是每场学校演出中的主角，而另一些孩子在课堂上很安静，只与一小群朋友交往。
Because our culture tends to prize being bold and outgoing, parents often worry about kids who seem too shy, but shyness as a trait isn't inherently good or bad. Today we're going to talk to a psychologist who studies temperament in young children about why some kids are shyer than others, how shyness develops from babyhood on and how parents and other caregivers can best support shy kids. So how do researchers define shyness? How do genes and environment interact to shape children's individual temperament and personality?
因为我们的文化倾向于推崇大胆和外向，父母常常担心那些看起来太害羞的孩子，但害羞作为一种特质，本身并没有好坏之分。今天，我们将与一位研究幼儿气质的心理学家探讨为什么有些孩子比其他孩子更害羞，害羞是如何从婴儿期开始发展的，以及父母和其他照料者如何最好地支持害羞的孩子。那么，研究人员是如何定义害羞的呢？基因和环境是如何相互作用来塑造儿童的个人气质和个性的？
Do shy kids tend to become shy adults or can our temperament change over our lifetime? What's the difference between shyness and introversion? What's the relationship between shyness and social anxiety? and how can parents help their shy kids recognize and tap into the strengths of their own temperament. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Corali Perez-Edgar, the McCourtney Professor of Child Studies and a Professor of Psychology at Penn State University. Her research focuses on temperament and young children, especially shyness, and the links between temperament and anxiety disorders.
害羞的孩子长大后会成为害羞的成年人吗？还是我们的气质会随着一生而改变？害羞和内向有什么区别？害羞与社交焦虑之间有什么关系？父母如何帮助害羞的孩子认识并利用他们自身气质的优势。欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是宾夕法尼亚州立大学儿童研究麦考特尼教授兼心理学教授科拉利·佩雷斯-埃德加博士。她的研究重点是幼儿的气质，尤其是害羞，以及气质与焦虑症之间的联系。
She's the author of hundreds of academic publications and has received many awards for her research and teaching, including Penn State's Graduate Faculty Teaching Award and the APA Division 7 Mentor Award. She's also editor-in-chief of APA's journal Developmental Psychology. Dr. Perez-Edgar, thank you for joining me today. Thank you for inviting me. In the introduction, I mentioned that you study temperament. How do researchers define temperament and what's the relationship between temperament and a personality trait like shyness?
她是数百篇学术出版物的作者，并因其研究和教学获得了许多奖项，包括宾夕法尼亚州立大学研究生院教学奖和美国心理学会第 7 分会导师奖。她还是美国心理学会期刊《发展心理学》的主编。佩雷斯-埃德加博士，感谢您今天加入我的节目。谢谢您的邀请。在介绍中，我提到您研究气质。研究人员如何定义气质，气质与害羞等性格特征之间有什么关系？
So there are three main pillars of what we would consider something to be a temperament. The first is that it's early appearing. The second is that it's biologically based. The third is that it is relatively stable over time. So early appearing means that for many temperaments, you can see individual differences across babies in the first months of life. That it's biologically based means that it's not determined by biology. It's not determined by genetics, but we can see relationships with how the body and the brain responds to different aspects of our environment. And the relatively stable means that across context and across time, we see similar patterns of
我们认为的气质主要有三大支柱。第一是出现得早。第二是基于生物学。第三是随着时间的推移相对稳定。所以“出现得早”意味着对于许多气质类型，你可以在婴儿出生后的头几个月里观察到个体差异。“基于生物学”意味着它不是由生物学决定的。它不是由遗传决定的，但我们可以看到身体和大脑对环境不同方面的反应之间存在联系。“相对稳定”意味着在不同的环境和时间里，我们观察到个体表现出相似的模式。
behavior in an individual. So those three things put together would put a particular behavioral profile as a temperament. Now, temperaments can be seen as the foundation for personality. So personality tends to arise based on events that occur in your life. your response to those events, and then how people respond to you. Your temperament tends to shape how those three things go over time. So that often some people will say that temperament is the biological basis of personality. So what are the various temperaments?
行为模式。所以这三点加在一起，就将特定的行为特征归类为气质。气质可以被视为个性的基础。个性往往是基于你生活中发生的事件、你对这些事件的反应，以及人们对你的反应而产生的。你的气质往往会塑造这三者随时间的发展。因此，人们常说气质是个性的生物学基础。那么，有哪些不同的气质呢？
Are they the same as, say, the big five personality characteristics, or those are not temperaments? Those are not temperaments. They can grow into each other. So a number of individuals have done research looking how does early temperament compare to or predict the Big Five. And those two constructs come from very different science traditions. So the Big Five came from using vocabulary and different understandings of what people were like to generate for now Big Five. five different areas of personality that people show in combination. The temperament literature starts in infancy looking at behavior and looking at underlying biology. So that type of research tries to do is say, how does a biologically based temperament match the personalities that we tend to see in our society?
它们和所谓的“大五人格”特征一样吗？还是说那些不是气质？那些不是气质。它们可以相互融合。许多人进行了研究，观察早期气质如何与“大五人格”进行比较或预测“大五人格”。这两个概念来自非常不同的科学传统。大五人格源于使用词汇和对人们特征的不同理解，从而生成了现在的“大五人格”——人们组合表现出的五种不同的人格领域。气质文献始于婴儿期，观察行为并研究潜在的生物学。因此，这类研究试图说明，基于生物学的气质如何与我们在社会中倾向于看到的个性相匹配？
There are some similarities. So one temperament that we see is negative reality. activity, the sensitivity to events in the environment and often your response is with negative affect, negative emotion. If that is coupled with early anxiety, early rigidity, that is similar to or predicts neuroticism among the big five. Children who show positive affect or high levels of positive emotion and surgency, they tend to have more of that open personality positive as an adult. So it's not a one-to-one, but one can predict the other. And so if I'm a mom, the temperament of my kid, I might notice as shortly after birth that I've got an easygoing child who sleeps,
它们有一些相似之处。我们看到的一种气质是负面情绪性，即对环境中事件的敏感性，通常你的反应是负面情感、负面情绪。如果这与早期的焦虑、早期的僵化相结合，就类似于或预测了大五人格中的神经质。表现出积极情感或高水平积极情绪和冲动性的儿童，成年后往往具有更多那种开放的个性。所以这不是一一对应的，但一种可以预测另一种。如果我是一位母亲，我可能会在孩子出生后不久就注意到孩子的气质，比如我有一个睡觉时很随和的孩子，
or I've got what I would call a cranky kid who doesn't want to sleep or is fussy, right? That's temperament. That's temperament, yes. And then some temperaments will emerge slightly later. So when we think about temperament, there are two big components of it, reactivity and regulation. So reactivity is what is in the moment your knee-jerk response to something that happens in your environment, a loud noise, a sound, frustration. Do you respond with anger, with a positive emotion? Do you tend to approach? Do you tend to withdraw? So that's reactivity. Regulation is effortful.
或者我有一个我称之为“暴躁”的孩子，他不睡觉或者很挑剔，对吧？那是气质。是的，那是气质。有些气质会稍晚出现。当我们思考气质时，它有两个主要组成部分：反应性和调节性。反应性是你对环境中发生的事情（如巨大的噪音、声音、挫折）的瞬间本能反应。你用愤怒还是积极的情绪来回应？你倾向于接近还是撤退？这就是反应性。调节性是需要努力的。
It's your ability to say, okay, this is my initial response. This is my go-to move. Let me see in this moment, should I change that response? Should I temper it? And regulation tends to emerge later in life, right? because you need those skills to stop, assess, and if needed, effortfully change. So reactivity emerges early in life with lots of different varieties. Regulation emerges a little bit later with the help and scaffolding of families, peers, and teachers.
这是你能够说：“好吧，这是我最初的反应。这是我的惯用动作。让我看看在这一刻，我是否应该改变这种反应？我是否应该缓和它？”调节性往往在生命后期出现，因为你需要这些技能来停止、评估，并在必要时努力改变。因此，反应性在生命早期出现，形式多样。调节性在家庭、同龄人和老师的帮助和引导下稍晚出现。
But they're both temperamental traits. They're both early appearing. They're both biologically based. And they're both relatively stable over time. Now, you work with very young children and even babies in your research. How do you gauge a baby's temperament? What are the techniques that you use? So we usually start doing the laboratory studies of temperament at around four months of age. Our understanding and our assumption is a lot of what happens in those first four months
但它们都是气质特征。它们都出现得早。它们都基于生物学。而且它们随着时间的推移都相对稳定。现在，您在研究中与非常年幼的儿童甚至婴儿一起工作。您如何评估婴儿的气质？您使用什么技术？我们通常在四个月大左右开始进行气质的实验室研究。我们的理解和假设是，前四个月发生的很多事情
are regulated by low-level brain, visceral, bodily functions, right? sleep, eat, poop, right? That's the cycle of the first three or four months. And you might have lots of babies with colic, for example. And it's not until about four months of age that stable individual differences emerge. And so, for example, for one type of temperament, reactivity, positive versus negative, we literally place a baby in a car seat and we give them a series of sensory stimulation. So, We will have them listen to an audio tape of voices that become increasingly complex and overlapping. We will show them a series of mobiles.
是由低级大脑、内脏、身体功能调节的，比如睡眠、进食、排便。这是前三四个月的周期。例如，你可能会有很多患有肠绞痛的婴儿。直到四个月大左右，稳定的个体差异才会出现。因此，例如，对于一种气质类型——反应性（积极与消极），我们实际上把婴儿放在汽车座椅上，给他们一系列感官刺激。所以，我们会让他们听声音越来越复杂且重叠的录音带。我们会给他们看一系列移动玩具。
Very simple, something you would find at the store, soft, plushy little animals. And we will show them one and then three and then five and then seven. In some studies, they give them things to smell on a cotton ball. And what you find is that for some babies, this is really interesting. They listen to the sounds. They look at the mobile. They sniff the cotton ball. And they're like, okay, you know, this is an interesting place.
非常简单，你在商店里能找到的那种，柔软的毛绒小动物。我们会先给他们看一个，然后是三个，然后是五个，然后是七个。在一些研究中，他们会给婴儿闻棉球上的东西。你会发现，对一些婴儿来说，这非常有趣。他们听声音，看移动玩具，闻棉球。他们会觉得，好吧，这是一个有趣的地方。
I'm just going to hang out and see what happens. And for some babies, that very same stimuli pushing them over the edge, they cry, they fuss, they try to self-soothe. some babies will try to flip over in the car seat just to try to get away. And it's really interesting because it's a simple mobile. Something a family, a parent might have bought anyway for the child. And it is just too much. It's sensory overload. And so that's where we separate babies out that are positively reactive and negatively reactive. How do they respond to novel, social stimuli in their environment? Do they want to approach?
我只是待在这里看看会发生什么。而对一些婴儿来说，同样的刺激让他们无法承受，他们哭闹、烦躁，试图自我安抚。有些婴儿甚至会试图在汽车座椅里翻身，想逃离。这真的很有趣，因为这只是一个简单的移动玩具。一个家庭或父母可能无论如何都会为孩子买的东西。但对他们来说，这太过了。这是感官超负荷。这就是我们区分积极反应和消极反应婴儿的地方。他们对环境中新颖的社交刺激有何反应？他们想接近吗？
positive emotion, do they want to withdraw negative emotion? I want to talk more about temperament, but I think we're here to talk a lot about shyness today, so let me throw that on the table. So when does shyness begin to appear in children? So this is where it's really interesting because my advisor when I was in graduate school would tell us that a lot of the confusion we have as scientist is that we tend to have a limited vocabulary. So we either use the same word for multiple different constructs or take the same construct and use a lot of fancy words to make it look like we discovered something new. So for the most part, shyness is a typical or normative behavior in young children. For the vast majority of children,
积极情绪，还是想撤退？消极情绪。我想多谈谈气质，但我想我们今天主要是来谈害羞的，所以让我把这个话题提出来。那么，害羞在儿童身上是什么时候开始出现的呢？这就是非常有趣的地方，因为我在读研究生时的导师曾告诉我们，我们作为科学家所面临的很多困惑在于，我们的词汇量有限。所以我们要么对多个不同的概念使用同一个词，要么对同一个概念使用很多华丽的词，让它看起来像是我们发现了什么新东西。所以，在很大程度上，害羞是幼儿的一种典型或规范行为。对于绝大多数孩子来说，
if you take them to a new place, preschool, to dance lesson, most children hang back a little bit. they might cling to their mom. And then after a little bit, when they realize things are pretty fun, they'll engage, right? So that's not in and of itself shyness. That's the normal sort of reticence that you would see in a young child. The most exuberant of children are the ones who don't show that. That you could literally drop them off in the middle of a department store. And they'd be like, oh, look at all this.
如果你带他们去一个新地方，比如幼儿园、舞蹈课，大多数孩子都会稍微退缩。他们可能会紧紧抓住妈妈。过了一会儿，当他们意识到事情很有趣时，他们就会参与进来，对吧？所以这本身并不是害羞。这是你在幼儿身上看到的正常的矜持。最活泼的孩子是那些不表现出这种矜持的孩子。你可以把他们直接扔在百货商店中间。他们会说，哦，看这一切。
This is fantastic. Let me go up and talk to people, right? that's not the typical child. So when we say most toddlers are shy, that's what we mean. When we think about shyness as a trait, as something that really defines someone, it is moving beyond that typical, I cling to my parent when I'm meeting someone new. It is that even as they grow older, three, four, five, six years of age, they're still hanging back. they're still clinging. They're still reticent to engage in new behavior and meet new people. That's where we generally will then think about, okay, that's a trait level.
这太棒了。让我走过去和人们交谈，对吧？那不是典型的孩子。所以当我们说大多数幼儿是害羞的时候，我们指的就是这个。当我们把害羞视为一种特质，视为真正定义某人的东西时，它就超越了那种典型的“我在遇到陌生人时紧紧抓住父母”的行为。即使随着年龄增长，三、四、五、六岁，他们仍然退缩。他们仍然紧紧抓住父母。他们仍然对参与新行为和结识新朋友感到矜持。这就是我们通常会考虑的，好吧，那是特质层面的。
That's shyness. This is someone who considers being in a social situation and makes them feel uncomfortable. Before they're in this situation, they're apprehensive. And they feel awkward when they're in that situation. So we can label that shyness. Some of that shyness is temperamentally based. So negative reactivity can predict behavioral inhibition, which is in toddlerhood, the freezing and inability to engage with social stimuli.
那是害羞。这是一个在社交场合感到不舒服的人。在进入这种情境之前，他们感到忧虑。当他们处于那种情境时，他们感到尴尬。所以我们可以称之为害羞。有些害羞是基于气质的。因此，负面反应性可以预测行为抑制，这在幼儿期表现为僵住和无法与社交刺激互动。
And that behavioral inhibition can lead to shyness. So some shy children are temperamentally shy. Some shy children are culturally shy. And what I mean by that is that parents, depending on the culture, inculcate shy-like behaviors because that is valued. And then some children become superficially shy because of negative experiences, bad things that have happened to them. So their response to that is to hang back. So similar behaviors can have very different antecedents. And part of what we do is developmental psychologist is try to tease those.
而这种行为抑制会导致害羞。所以有些害羞的孩子是气质上的害羞。有些害羞的孩子是文化上的害羞。我的意思是，父母根据文化的不同，会灌输类似害羞的行为，因为这被认为是值得赞赏的。还有一些孩子因为负面经历、发生在他们身上的坏事而变得表面上害羞。所以他们对此的反应是退缩。因此，相似的行为可能有非常不同的前因。作为发展心理学家，我们所做的一部分工作就是试图理清这些。
apart. Can we tell the difference between temperamental shyness, cultural shyness, and then shyness that it's a reflection of previous difficult events? And based on what you previously said about temperament, it would seem that temperamental shyness would be the one that is most innate and not changeable. It's less changeable. I think one of the things we try to say about temperament, it is clay. And clay is more. moldable. And you can shape something out of clay based on the culture, based on parenting, based on relationships with peers. And so it's not always going to look the same. However,
分开来看。我们能区分气质性害羞、文化性害羞以及反映先前困难事件的害羞吗？根据您之前关于气质的说法，似乎气质性害羞是最天生且不可改变的。它较难改变。我认为我们试图关于气质说的一件事是，它是粘土。粘土更具可塑性。你可以根据文化、教养、与同龄人的关系，用粘土塑造出东西。所以它不会总是看起来一样。然而，
clay does have its own form. It has its limits, right? You can't turn clay into glass. You can't turn the behaviorally inhibited, negatively reacted infant into the life of the party, big man on campus, without doing a lot to that child. So it's moldable. It's not infinite. If you're a parent and you notice that your baby or toddler, it seems to be shy, should you be worried and is there anything that you should do? I think if the child is capable of doing the typical things for their age and other children, no, there is no worry. I think the problem is sometimes our expectations of what we think are typical are not typical. So for example, if you take your child, let's use the example of dance class again, and you show up and you see the child that just
粘土有它自己的形状。它有它的局限性，对吧？你不能把粘土变成玻璃。你不能在不对孩子做很多干预的情况下，把行为受抑制、反应消极的婴儿变成派对的灵魂人物、校园里的风云人物。所以它是可塑的。它不是无限的。如果你是一位父母，你注意到你的婴儿或幼儿似乎很害羞，你应该担心吗？你应该做些什么吗？我认为如果孩子有能力做他们那个年龄段和其他孩子能做的典型事情，不，不用担心。我认为问题在于，有时我们对什么是典型的期望并不典型。例如，如果你带你的孩子，让我们再次使用舞蹈课的例子，你到了那里，看到那个孩子
let's go of their parent's hand, runs in happily, is immediately engaged, right? We value that. type of exuberance and confidence and positivity. And we mistake that for typicality. That's not typical. Most children are slow to warm up. Most children will need a little time to get in there. It's the very shy child who says, I don't want to go at all.
松开父母的手，快乐地跑进去，立即投入其中，对吧？我们重视那种活泼、自信和积极的类型。我们误以为那是典型。那不是典型的。大多数孩子需要时间来热身。大多数孩子需要一点时间才能进入状态。是那个非常害羞的孩子说，我根本不想去。
And it's not that I don't like dance. I don't want to do any activities. It's I don't want to do soccer. I don't want to do swimming. When it inhibits their ability to now, navigate and negotiate their lives because children have lives, that's when you worry. But we want to make sure we don't assume that the gregarious independent child is the typical child because that's not the typical child. That's the valued child in our Western culture.
并不是我不喜欢跳舞。我不想参加任何活动。而是我不想踢足球。我不想游泳。当它抑制了他们现在导航和协商生活的能力时——因为孩子也有生活——那才是你担心的时候。但我们要确保不要假设那个合群、独立的孩子才是典型的孩子，因为那不是典型的孩子。那是我们西方文化中受重视的孩子。
But that's not the same thing. Now, what is the difference between shyness and introversion? So introversion is more of a personality trait. It is often more studied as you get older into adolescence, young adulthood. The thing about introversion, it often looks at the way in which you gain energy as an individual. So some of us gain energy by being in a social setting, by engaging in activities with others. That recharges our batteries. We fuel up, right? Those are the extroverts in our lives. Introverts tend to deplete their battery when they are in those big, loud social settings.
但这并不是一回事。那么，害羞和内向有什么区别呢？内向更多是一种人格特质。它通常在进入青春期、成年早期时被研究得更多。关于内向，它通常关注你作为个体获得能量的方式。所以我们中的一些人通过处于社交环境中、与他人进行活动来获得能量。这能给我们的电池充电。我们加满了油，对吧？那些是我们生活中的外向者。内向者在那些大型、嘈杂的社交场合中往往会耗尽电池。
And they go home. They sit quietly with a mug of tea in a book. That recharges their battery. So they're doing that because they enjoy it. Being at home or quiet or being with one or two close friends, that recharges them. that is something they wish to do, that is beneficial to them. That introverted side of them is making them feel good. The shy individual, the withdrawn individual is moving back from the world out of fear, out of anxiety, out of apprehension. They are staying inside because they are afraid to be outside. And so that's the difference.
他们回家。他们安静地坐着，喝杯茶，看本书。这能给他们的电池充电。所以他们这样做是因为他们喜欢。待在家里、安静或与一两个亲密朋友在一起，这能给他们充电。这是他们希望做的事情，这对他们是有益的。他们内向的一面让他们感觉良好。害羞的人、退缩的人是因为恐惧、焦虑、忧虑而从世界中退缩。他们待在里面是因为他们害怕待在外面。这就是区别。
Are you being pulled in because it recharges? you, are you staying in because you're afraid to engage? And that's where those two things, I think, anxiety and shyness can interfere with your life. Introversion helps you shape your life. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199, and entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499.9. This Memorial Day, get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price-in-valed May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions apply.
你是被吸引进去的，因为它能为你充电吗？你是待在里面是因为你害怕参与吗？这就是我认为焦虑和害羞会干扰你生活的地方。内向则能帮助你塑造生活。你的夏天从家得宝的阵亡将士纪念日促销开始。是时候用 Nextgrill 四炉头燃气烧烤架开启夏季烧烤了，特价仅需 199 美元，并用 Hampton Bay West Grove 七件套户外餐桌椅套装尽情娱乐整个季节，仅需 499.9 美元。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受低价保证。售完即止，价格有效期至 5 月 14 日或 5 月 27 日，仅限美国，适用排除条款。
see Home Depot.com slash price match for details. Are shy children more likely to develop into teens or adults with social anxiety? Temperamentally shy children, yes. So what we can say is depending on how you look at the data. And of course, data is always so beautiful because it's malleable. If we think of the child who was behaviorally inhibited as a toddler, they have an up to sixfold chance of being socially anxious as an adolescent or as a young adult. And so that seems like a huge number, six times as likely than the average individual. If you flip the data a little bit, it's a 50-50 shot.
详情请见 HomeDepot.com/pricematch。害羞的孩子长大后更有可能成为患有社交焦虑的青少年或成年人吗？气质上害羞的孩子，是的。所以我们可以说，这取决于你看待数据的方式。当然，数据总是那么美妙，因为它是可塑的。如果我们想到那个在幼儿期表现出行为抑制的孩子，他们成为青少年或成年早期社交焦虑者的几率高达六倍。这看起来是一个巨大的数字，是普通人的六倍。如果你稍微翻转一下数据，那就是五五开。
So about 40 to 60% of behaviorally inhibited, temperamentally shy children go on to be socially anxious. So depending on how you feel that morning, you can be very pessimistic, six times as likely, or pretty optimistic and like, it's a flip of a coin. So us as a developmental psychologist, let's study and figure out why does the coin land on heads versus tails. And if tails is anxiety, what can we do to prevent? that and boost the chance for heads. And so we see that. We can trace it from the earliest months of life. And so that's where we go back to look at the biology, to look at culture, to look at parenting, to again change those odds, even if ever so slightly. A lot of your work
所以大约 40% 到 60% 的行为受抑制、气质上害羞的孩子后来会患上社交焦虑。所以根据你那天早上的感觉，你可以非常悲观（六倍的可能性），或者相当乐观（像抛硬币一样）。作为发展心理学家，让我们研究并找出为什么硬币会正面朝上而不是反面朝上。如果反面是焦虑，我们能做些什么来预防它并增加正面朝上的机会？我们看到了这一点。我们可以从生命的最早几个月追踪它。所以这就是我们回到生物学、文化、教养方面去寻找原因，再次改变这些几率，即使只是微小的改变。您的很多工作
is focused on the role of attention in temperament and in traits like shyness. Can you tell us how attention and temperament are connected. Attention is very important. It is pivotal to development. It allows us to selectively choose what aspects of our environment. We process, we interpret, we act on, and we remember.
都集中在注意力在气质和害羞等特质中的作用。您能告诉我们注意力和气质是如何联系在一起的吗？注意力非常重要。它对发展至关重要。它使我们能够有选择地选择我们环境中的哪些方面。我们处理、解释、行动并记住它们。
If you don't attend to something, it's very difficult to do those things. And we need to have selective attention. There's too much happening in our world at any one time to take it all in. And if we tried to, we would freeze in our tracks. It would be too overwhelming. So the way in which we selectively attend to what aspects of our environment
如果你不关注某件事，就很难做到这些。我们需要有选择性注意力。我们的世界在任何时候都有太多的事情发生，无法全部吸收。如果我们试图这样做，我们就会僵在原地。那会让人不知所措。所以我们有选择地关注环境哪些方面的方式
shapes what we call the experienced environment. So let's take an example of a classroom. They're in the room, two children sitting in the same location. They go through the day with the teacher and their peers. You can ask one child, how did school go today? And they're like, fantastic. We had to do reading time. We did arts and crafts.
塑造了我们所谓的“体验环境”。让我们以教室为例。在房间里，两个孩子坐在同一个位置。他们和老师及同龄人一起度过了一天。你可以问一个孩子，今天学校过得怎么样？他们会说，太棒了。我们有阅读时间。我们做了手工。
Everybody thought it was so funny. It was really hard so that what we made looked really silly, but isn't that great? And we just laughed all about it and wasn't it fun? The second child, how was school today? It was awful. We had to do reading time. And so I had to sit there with everybody. And then we had to do arts and crafts.
每个人都觉得太搞笑了。这真的很难，所以我们做的东西看起来很傻，但那不是很好吗？我们只是笑个不停，难道不有趣吗？第二个孩子，今天学校怎么样？太糟糕了。我们必须进行阅读时间。所以我不得不和大家坐在一起。然后我们必须做手工。
And it was so hard. And everything I did looked so dumb and they all laugh. and they all laughed at me, and I could tell that. So they're taking the same events. They're attending to different aspects of that event, and they're interpreting it very differently. And so for one child, school is supportive, it's fun, it's someplace I want to go again.
这太难了。我做的一切看起来都很笨，他们都笑。他们都嘲笑我，我能感觉到。所以他们经历的是同样的事件。他们关注的是该事件的不同方面，并且他们的解释方式截然不同。所以对于一个孩子来说，学校是支持性的，是有趣的，是我愿意再次去的地方。
For the other child, it's threatening, it's downright mean, and why would I want to subject myself to that again? So they're attending to different things. They're interpreting it differently, subjectively, and they're responding accordingly. Because if you think something is good for you, you approach. If you think something is threatening, you withdraw. Both kids are being very logical.
对于另一个孩子，它是威胁性的，简直是刻薄的，我为什么要让自己再次经历那种事？所以他们关注的是不同的事情。他们主观地以不同的方式解释它，并做出相应的反应。因为如果你认为某件事对你有好处，你就会接近。如果你认为某件事具有威胁性，你就会退缩。两个孩子都非常合乎逻辑。
They're just interpreting the world very differently. So if you have a child who interprets the world as scary, as threatening, as unpredictable, and my temperament wants predictability, and my temperament is sensitive to threat. Well, I'm going to react accordingly and I'm going to avoid that environment. So attention shapes our world because it shapes our worldview. We don't live the same lives, even if we're sitting side by side with each other, because we filter it very differently. How does the parent of the child who feels so negative about school,
他们只是以非常不同的方式解释世界。所以如果你有一个孩子，他把世界解释为可怕的、威胁性的、不可预测的，而我的气质想要可预测性，我的气质对威胁很敏感。好吧，我会做出相应的反应，我会避免那种环境。所以注意力塑造了我们的世界，因为它塑造了我们的世界观。我们并没有过同样的生活，即使我们并排坐在一起，因为我们过滤它的方式截然不同。那个对学校感觉如此消极的孩子的父母，
deal with that? How do you help the child to attend differently? Slowly and step by step. So one of the things that I think is really helpful in a lot of schools do this just as an open thing for all children. If you think of it and you put yourself back in the mind of the five-year-old going into kindergarten, for us as adults, it's very standard. We have in our brain the schema of what a classroom looks like, what school looks like, what the daily activities are like. It seems normal to us. That five-year-old who maybe hasn't been in preschool before or is going to a new school, there is nothing in their mind to hang on to.
该如何处理呢？你如何帮助孩子以不同的方式去关注？慢慢地，一步一步地。所以我认为很多学校在做的一件非常有帮助的事情，就是对所有孩子开放。如果你想一想，把自己放回五岁孩子进入幼儿园的心态，对于我们成年人来说，这是非常标准的。我们的大脑中有关于教室是什么样子、学校是什么样子、日常活动是什么样子的图式。这对我们来说似乎很正常。那个可能以前没上过幼儿园或者要去新学校的五岁孩子，他们脑子里没有什么可以依靠的东西。
What does my class look like? Where will I sit? What will I be asked to do? How does recess work? Well, what is recess, right? And the inhibited child, the shy child, wants information, wants to understand. understand what will be happening, doesn't like unpredictability. So, meeting the teacher before school starts, walking into the classroom, physically laying
我的教室是什么样子的？我坐在哪里？我会被要求做什么？课间休息是怎么运作的？什么是课间休息，对吧？而受抑制的孩子、害羞的孩子，想要信息，想要理解。理解将会发生什么，不喜欢不可预测性。所以，在开学前见到老师，走进教室，亲手
hands on, this is where I will sit, picturing that environment, it won't remove all of the anxiety or the apprehension, but it gives concreteness. And children, especially shy children, need that. concreteness to then build off of, slowly acclimating them to new things that scare them. And I think this is the worst advice, and I would have hated this advice when my children were little. Mine are 19 and 23 now. So, but it's don't do too much and don't do too little. It's the Goldilocks, just, just right. And the analogy I use is sitting at the edge of the swimming pool. This child needs to learn to swim.
触摸，这是我坐的地方，想象那个环境，它不会消除所有的焦虑或忧虑，但它提供了具体性。孩子们，尤其是害羞的孩子，需要那种具体性来作为基础，慢慢地让他们适应那些让他们害怕的新事物。我认为这是最糟糕的建议，如果我的孩子小时候听到这个建议，我会很讨厌。我的孩子现在 19 岁和 23 岁了。所以，但它是“不要做得太多，也不要做得太少”。这是“金发姑娘原则”，刚刚好。我用的类比是坐在游泳池边。这个孩子需要学习游泳。
God forbid they were to fall into the pool, they would drown. So it is up to you to teach them to swim. You don't necessarily want to pick them up and throw them in the deep end and hope for the best. You don't necessarily want to say, oh, this pool is scary, so we're just going to sit here and get our feet wet and never get beyond our knees. The first probably will scare the child, and they're like, I'm never getting in a pool again. the second will not equip them with the skills they need. We need to slowly get them in the water, slowly get them to paddle and slowly let go.
天哪，如果他们掉进游泳池，他们会淹死的。所以教他们游泳是你的责任。你不一定想把他们抱起来扔进深水区，祈祷一切顺利。你也不一定想说，哦，这个游泳池很可怕，所以我们只是坐在这里，弄湿脚，永远不要超过膝盖。前者可能会吓坏孩子，他们会说，我再也不进游泳池了。后者不会让他们掌握所需的技能。我们需要慢慢地让他们下水，慢慢地让他们划水，慢慢地放手。
And in many ways, our society requires certain skills to survive, and it is up to parents to give their children those skills. But we don't just kick them out of the house and say good luck, and we don't show up with them everywhere they go holding their hands. we scaffold them at the beginning and then we let go. Yes, we'll take you to preschool on day one. Maybe we'll stay for a little bit on day two,
在许多方面，我们的社会需要某些技能才能生存，而赋予孩子这些技能是父母的责任。但我们不会只是把他们踢出家门说祝你好运，我们也不会在他们去任何地方时都牵着他们的手。我们在开始时引导他们，然后我们放手。是的，第一天我们会带你去幼儿园。第二天我们可能会待一会儿，
but then slowly one day we will just drop you off and we will go because the child needs to learn that skill. And if the child doesn't naturally learn that school, then we bring in help. Is it harder for shy parents to do this? Yes, very much so. I think there are different ways in which parental temperament and child temperament interact that can make things easier and harder.
但后来慢慢地有一天我们就会把你放下，然后我们就会走，因为孩子需要学习那种技能。如果孩子没有自然地学到那种技能，那么我们就引入帮助。害羞的父母这样做会更难吗？是的，非常难。我认为父母气质和孩子气质相互作用的方式不同，这会让事情变得更容易或更难。
There are researchers, for example, Andrea Kronis-Chaskano at University of Maryland, who studies children with ADHD that tend to be loud, boisterous, exuberant, and not really well-regulated or structured. And what she found is a lot of times their parent has ADHD. So getting the parent and the child in sync is necessary. If you are a shy parent and you're not that thrilled with going out and meeting new people, you can have the tendency to say, oh, okay, that's fine. We don't have to do the play date because you don't want to do the play date either, right? God for, you know, I was tried to pick play dates with people that I knew so that I would feel comfortable, right?
例如，马里兰大学的安德里亚·克罗尼斯-查斯卡诺（Andrea Kronis-Chaskano）研究患有 ADHD 的儿童，他们往往大声、喧闹、活泼，且调节或结构化能力不强。她发现很多时候他们的父母也有 ADHD。所以让父母和孩子同步是必要的。如果你是一个害羞的父母，你对出去结识新朋友并不感到兴奋，你可能会倾向于说，哦，好吧，没关系。我们不必参加那个游戏约会，因为你也不想参加，对吧？天哪，你知道，我总是试着选择我认识的人进行游戏约会，这样我会感到舒服，对吧？
And I think so if there are things that you have difficulty with, that can make it more difficult for you to then feel empathetic for your child. If you're an exuberant parent, it might be completely unfathomable to you that this child would rather sit on the bleachers and read a book because that's not who you were. What got you interested in studying shyness and temperament? Are you a shy person, may I ask? I think fundamentally I am, but my graduate advisor, Jerome Kagan, was one of the first to describe temperamental shyness, behavioral inhibition. And one of the things that's very noteworthy about behaviorally inhibited children is they're slow to speak and they don't speak much. But what he found is by adolescence, some of these children turned into like parrots. And I think what he noticed is that they were talking as a form of protection. They knew they were shy.
我认为，如果你有困难的事情，这会让你更难对你的孩子产生共鸣。如果你是一个活泼的父母，你可能完全无法理解为什么这个孩子宁愿坐在看台上看书，因为那不是你。是什么让您对研究害羞和气质感兴趣？请问您是一个害羞的人吗？我认为从根本上说我是，但我研究生导师杰罗姆·卡根（Jerome Kagan）是第一批描述气质性害羞、行为抑制的人之一。关于行为受抑制的儿童，非常值得注意的一点是，他们说话慢，说得不多。但他发现，到了青春期，其中一些孩子变成了“鹦鹉”。我认为他注意到的是，他们说话是一种保护形式。他们知道自己害羞。
They knew they had difficulty interacting with others. So they were just going to flood the zone, right? They were just going to flood it all. And so I do think I'm fundamentally shy. I have worked to overcompensate by trying to push myself into these situations, being socially engaged, being willing to speak up and be part of the dialogue, and then going home and collapsing, right? And just like putting my head into my pillow, as opposed to the people who, you know,
他们知道自己与他人互动有困难。所以他们只是要淹没这个区域，对吧？他们只是要淹没一切。所以我确实认为我从根本上是害羞的。我努力通过强迫自己进入这些情境来补偿，变得善于社交，愿意发言并参与对话，然后回家崩溃，对吧？就像把头埋进枕头里，而不是那些真正从这些社交互动中获得充电的人。我认为很多人都是这样，他们向别人展示的形象不是他们自然的反应。这是他们的调节，对吧？人们在美国和新西兰进行长期研究发现。例如，新西兰的达尼丁研究招募了 1971 年至 1973 年间在达尼丁出生的几乎每个孩子。他们随着时间的推移跟踪他们。他们发现的一件事是，早期个性、早期气质塑造了——不是决定了，而是塑造了——他们从事的职业类型。
really get recharged by these social interactions. I think a lot of people are like that, that the picture they showed to others is not their natural reactivity. It's their regulation, right? what people have found doing long-term research in the United States and in New Zealand. So, for example, the Dunedin study in New Zealand enrolled practically every child born in Dunedin from 1971 to 1973. And they followed them over time. And one of the things they found is that early personality, early temperament, shapes, doesn't determine but shapes the types of careers they have.
所以那个稍微害羞、稍微笨拙、稍微内向的人可能更有可能成为会计师，更有可能成为实验室里的科学家。那个合群、开放、喜欢社交互动的人可能是一个拿佣金的销售员，对吧？他们都同样聪明。他们都是同样好的人。但如果你让他们交换角色，那将是一场灾难，对吧？这就是找到自己的定位并允许个人这样做的一点。所以对我来说，我的定位是在实验室工作，和孩子们一起工作，安静地打字，在需要的时候变得更善于社交。
So the slightly shy, slightly awkward, slightly introverted person might be more likely to be an accountant, be more likely to be a scientist in the lab. The person who's gregarious, open, loves social interactions might be a salesperson working on commission, right? They're both equally smart. They're both equally good people. But if you had them swap roles, it would be a disaster, right? And it's such a point of finding your niche and allowing individuals to do that. So for me, my niche is working in the lab, working with kids, doing a lot of typing quietly, and when I need to, being more social.
害羞的性格有优势吗？我认为可以有。我认为就像在西方工业化国家，我们倾向于试图让孩子更外向，把他们拉出来一点一样。有很多父母试图让他们的孩子慢下来，沉思，把事情想清楚，然后再行动，对吧？那个非常活泼、非常冲动的孩子往往难以调节那种“冲、冲、冲”。
Are there advantages to a shire personality? I think there can be. I think in the same way that in the Western industrialized countries, we tend to try to make children more outgoing to pull them out a little bit. There are a lot of parents trying to get their kids to slow down, contemplate, think things through, then out, right? The very exuberant, very surgent child often has difficulty with regulating the go, go, go.
我认为害羞、受抑制的孩子拥有的一个优势是，他们有时间去观察、去发现模式、去建立一种比你不让自己有那种反思时间更深刻的世界知识。如果你看动物文献，你可以观察动物的气质，对吧？它们通常被称为“新恐惧症”。例如，患有新恐惧症的老鼠害怕新事物。患有新嗜好症的老鼠，对吧？非人类灵长类动物（猕猴）也是如此。不随意跑进这个新环境并让自己被吃掉，这有一个生存成分，对吧？缓慢、确定且稳定。现在，如果你的部落或群体中的每个人都缓慢、确定且稳定，你可能会饿死，因为你不愿意翻过山去寻找新的食物来源。所以大多数社区
I think one of the things that the shy inhibited child has as an advantage, is they have the time to look, to observe, to pick up patterns, to build a knowledge of the world that can be a little deeper than if you don't let yourself have that reflective time. If you look at the animal literature, so you can look at temperament in animals, right? Often they're called neophobia's. The neophobic rat, for example, is scared of new things. The neophilic rat, a right? Same thing with non-human primates, mecacques. There is a survival component of not running into this new environment, willy-nilly, and getting yourself eaten, right? Slow and sure and steady. Now, if everybody in your tribe or in your pack was slow and sure and steady, you might starve to death because you're unwilling to go over the mountain to find the new source of food. So most communities
都有大胆和害羞的混合。正是几个世纪以来的这种混合，使得该物种得以生存。大胆和害羞的人类使我们的社会得以生存。我们需要两者。所以最后，我想在最后问一个问题，您现在在研究什么？您试图回答的重大问题是什么？我们对气质生物学的了解是基于我们在实验室中设计的任务和情境。例如，对于幼儿、婴儿，我们可能会拿出“弹簧盒”。有些孩子对弹簧盒感到非常兴奋。有些则感到恐惧。
have a mix of the bold and the bashful. And it's that mix over the centuries that allows that species to survive. The bold and the bashful humans allow our society to survive. We need both. So just to wrap up, question I like to ask at the end is, what are you working on now? What are the big questions that you're trying to answer? One of the things we know about the biology of temperament is based on tasks and situations that we contrive in the laboratory. So, for example, for the young child, the infant, we might bring out the jack in the box. And you have some children that are just thrilled by the jack-in-box. Some are terrified.
木偶，对吧，泡泡，爬楼梯，穿过隧道。我们在实验室里做的事情是为了创造风险和回报。这只能告诉我们当孩子离开实验室去学校、去操场或在家里与父母和兄弟姐妹协商日常生活时会发生什么。所以我们正在尝试做的一件事是在技术和概念上推动自己，我们能从孩子和青少年的角度看待他们实际存在领域的世界吗？所以我们能在他们参与社交活动时测量他们的心跳和心率，以观察交感神经和副交感神经活动吗？
Puppets, right, bubbles, climbing stairs, walking through a tunnel. things that we do in the lab to create risk and reward. That tells us only so much about what happens when the child leaves the lab and goes to school or goes to the playground or negotiates daily life in the home with the parents and the siblings. So one of the things we're trying to do is push ourselves technologically and conceptually, can we see the world from the point of view of children and adolescents in their actual realm of being? So can we measure their heartbeats and their heart rate while they're engaged in social activity to look at sympathetic and parasympathetic activity?
我们能有移动眼动仪，让你真正从这个孩子的角度看世界吗？我们能有移动脑电图或功能性近红外光谱仪，这样我们就能观察社交世界中的大脑活动吗？现在，其中一些东西的问题是它们看起来真的很奇怪。所以如果你头上戴着脑电图帽走来走去，没有人会正常地对你做出反应。但尽我们所能，我们能在实验室范围之外开展工作吗？在科学文献中，我们谈论生态效度。我们在实验室中所做的事情能告诉我们关于生态的信息，或预测这个孩子在现实世界中实际发生的事情吗？
Can we have mobile eye trackers that literally let you see the world from the point of view of this child? can we have mobile EEG or FNIRs so we can look at brain activity in the social world? Now, the problem with some of these things is they look really weird. So nobody's going to react to you normally if you're walking around with an EEG cap on your head. But to the best of our ability, can we do our work outside the confines of our laboratory? In the science literature, we talk about ecological validity. Can the things we do in our lab tell us about the ecology or predict what's actually happening in the real world of this child?
我们能否拥有移动式眼动仪，让我们真正从这个孩子的视角看世界？我们能否拥有移动式脑电图（EEG）或功能性近红外光谱（FNIRs），以便观察社交环境中的大脑活动？现在，这些设备的问题在于它们看起来非常奇怪。如果你戴着脑电图帽走来走去，没人会以正常的方式对待你。但我们能否尽最大努力，在实验室之外开展工作？在科学文献中，我们谈论生态效度。我们在实验室中所做的事情，能否反映生态环境，或预测这个孩子在现实世界中究竟发生了什么？
So slowly but surely is gaining more ecological validity. I think that's the next frontier for us. Well, Dr. Perez-Edgar, I want to thank you for joining me today. This has been very interesting. Thank you again. This has been a great conversation. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.w.combeingof Psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts.
所以，它正缓慢但肯定地获得更多的生态效度。我认为这是我们接下来的前沿领域。好的，Perez-Edgar博士，非常感谢您今天能参加我们的节目。这非常有意思。再次感谢您。这是一次很棒的谈话。您可以在我们的网站www.speakingofpsychology.org，或者在Apple、Spotify、YouTube或任何您收听播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》往期的节目。
And if you like what you've heard, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening. for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果您喜欢我们的节目，请留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。 《心理学谈话》由Lee Weinerman制作。感谢您收听美国心理学会的节目。我是Kim Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。